ah what are we doing here what are we
doing here quick video let's get it hey
what is going on yeah good
toejam smelling ass [ __ ] ass boys I'm
gonna be traveling to Atlanta and Vegas
for what's it called a sin foods episode
so I got to get a couple of these videos
in because I said I'd be creating
content you already know is you know
sometimes I get too much in my head and
I'm like oh man what should I create
sometimes we just got it yeah just we
just got do stuff you know I'm saying
well today's videos that we're gonna
talk about man I gotta tell you to this
video I'm about to show y'all God die no
I don't think I've laughed this [ __ ]
hard at a video in my life in this video
clip you are going to see a child
imitate the noises and the sounds that
he heard we can watch TV on my computer
though so number one you already know
this kid is already too smart for his
age because this little guy is not
having it he got that face like his mom
said in the most nervous voice possible
we was watching a movie what movie you
watching inspect their gadgets heavy
Twatter and the Sorcerer's bone the
incredible bulk ass Ventura the crack
detective The Da Vinci load Forrest hump
Edward penis has the child responded
with basically beef funniest thing I've
ever heard he called his mom out
the movie will be watching sometimes we
can watch TV on my computer though he
basically said you know your brokers
don't got a TV in your bedroom trying to
lie to my innocent child spirits you
know a parent is cornered by their
child's comments whether you start
making up objects in their bedroom that
never existed maybe one wasn't [ __ ]
down the sound of a pet dragon getting
stabbed by a mystical sword that's that
that's what did you god I pray that you
don't give me a child this smart with
that grade of listening skills because
he imitated her to the [ __ ] tee
this lady was getting her guts stepped
in with the force of a thousand
waterfall if you really listen to the
[ __ ] that he's imitating he literally
imitated his mom getting [ __ ] and his
dad nutty I don't have kids so I was
wondering what parents do when they
wanna [ __ ] and their kids are awake I
would beat my kids ass and send them to
their room so they didn't worry about
the noises coming from from my room oh
you just tell you chosen that Mommy has
an evil spirit inside her every night
and daddy gotta beat the [ __ ] out of the
demons with his dick I didn't know who
this lady is simply because I need to
know who the man is because I don't
think I've ever [ __ ] somebody that
hard where they sound like a Japanese
ghost
oh sorry use the decoy so good well
thanks for setting that video and guys
uh I [ __ ] love the Internet man if it
wasn't for the Internet we wouldn't get
these videos but yeah man quick video
see y'all next time these topics
subjects videos whatever it can be
Twitter videos video content and general
advice whatever you guys want leave it
in the comments below we try to make
ya'll laugh on a weekly basis I'm
traveling a lot right now so it's kind
of hard to make these videos but I'll do
what I can man you know I'm saying I'm
puttin you but love you guys do what you
got to do see y'all next time
let's have sex bye
on our way to go get some Vietnamese
food from my very very very good friends
Vince and land
Vincent Lin I actually know from
Sacramento Vince I grew up with and I
met him back in the day through my
cousin but ever since I met him we